the versatile gentleman who will make
the award to the supporting actress of
the year isn't himself a former Academy
Award winner he is distinguished himself
in so many branches of the arts as actor
director playwright essayist lecturer
and producer it seems a shame he does
not have a middle name because Peter
Ustinov SMAW no Graham should be
anything but pu if he doesn't object
then here is Peter a Houston
thank you Bob for finding a solution to
what has been a sticky situation for
years now see what you can do with
oscar-winner
for the best performance by an actress
in a supporting role Academy members in
the year 1966 nominated the following
ladies
Joyce Redman in a fellow Maggie Smith
also in a fellow Ruth Gordon in inside
Daisy clover Shelley Winters in a patch
of blue and piggy would in The Sound of
Music
patients ladies while the winner is
Shelley Winters
thank you very much members of the
Academy for giving this to me the second
time in my life I wish to thank very
much my director mr. guy green who truly
understood the role I played better than
I did and I would like to especially
thank mr. Pendrell Berman for not only
making such a sensitive beautiful
picture about a subject of integration
such as a patch of blue ears but for
making the picture of box office success
which is very important for subjects
like these and I like to take my agent
again her brother thank you